[موسيقى]
نعيش خلال هذه الايام بخيريه العقارب ربيع
متفشي واعتدال في درجات الحراره لكنها لا
تخلو من هجمات برد مباغته ولهذا سميت
بالعقارب الى ادخله العقارب ترى الخير
قارب وهو موسم تبادل المنفعه بين الباديه
والحاضره والبحاره الباديه يزودون الحاضره
بس سمن
والملبوسات والحاضره يزودونهم بالزبد
والتمر والبحاره يزودونهم بالحلي ولا منه
خلصت العقارب نقول لشته اللي شبكنا معك يا
حلو خلصنا يكفينا اللي حصل ما نستحمل
زياده
[تصفيق]
والعقارب داخله في حيز الامطار الصيفيه
والعامه يسمونها بامطار اسماك نسبه الى
نجم اسماك فامطاره منبته للحمض والحنظل لا
تسقني ماء الحياه بذله بل فاسقني بالعزي
كاس الحنظلي ان كنت في عدد العبيد فهمتي
فوق الثريا والسماك
الاعزمه
[موسيقى]